news daily from science mission
scientists demonstrate micro RNA 17 292
are required for development of lateral
motor column located at the brachial and
lumbar spinal cord levels and its
innervation into limb muscles they show
that increased expression of micro RNA
17 292 during embryonic development
there is a speed and expression and the
connection while deletion of these
microRNAs lead to increased pete and
expression abomination and neuronal
death next when pathogenic equal I
called you back in fact bladder
epithelial cells they are targeted to
lysosomes but avoid degredation because
of their capacity to neutralize
lysosomal pH this change is detected by
a transient receptor potential cation
channel TRP channel 3 localized to
lysosomes which then subsequently
initiates lysosome exocytosis resulting
in expulsion of exosome encased bacteria
thereby protecting the cells next
metastasis of breast cancer leads to
bone lesions where bone is destroyed in
eighty-five percent advanced cases
scientists show that in hypoxic team our
environment in east origin receptor
negative breast cancer lifestyle oxidase
is released from the tumors it enters
the bloodstream and act on osteoclast
leading to bone lesion for more details
visit us www science mission calm and
science mission facebook page thanks for
watching